Dr Zak here regarding the situation of a
woman who is on her period or
Menses um she is Forgiven or she is let
off from having to do the prayer and she
doesn't have to make up the prayer at a
later date as we've learned in previous
Series in this uh
show um what is the case with fasting is
it the same uh as far as fasting is
concerned if a lady is having a Min
periods according to Hadith which is
mentioned
in say bukari volume number three in the
book of fasting Hadith number
1951 AA may be pleased with her will the
wife of prophet M wasallam she said when
she was asked this question that do we
have to make up for the fast or does the
Fast Break were minrating so she said
that when we used to
fast and when when we used to have a
menstruations during the month of
Ramadan she used to say that during the
month of Ramadan when we had a
menstruation the prophet asked us to
make up for the fast but did not ask us
to make up for the Salah So based on the
ruling of wasallam which was narrated To
Us by his
wife so making up for the prayer is not
a requirement but making up for the fast
is a requirement so if a woman has a
menstrual cycle or post nle bleeding she
cannot continue with the fast the fast
breaks if she has in between in the day
she'll have to break the fast or even if
the menstruation starts just a few
minutes before Sunset she'll have to
break the fast the fast is not valid but
if menstruation stops just before faj
then she can keep the fast but if the
menstruation stops just a few minutes
after fajer she cannot keep the fast and
she will have to make up the fast later
on after Ramadan the reason why the
fasting breaks when a woman has a
menstrual period or post Nal bleeding is
because a lot of blood flows out and
Allah subhana wa ta'ala does not want to
overburden the woman so it's a Grace
from Allah subhana wa taala he does not
want to make it difficult because when
blood flows out and then after that if
you say that you should not take
nourishment should not take food it's a
over burdening so because of that Allah
subhana tala has excused the woman that
she need not fast but she has to make up
later on the reason she has to make up
the fast later on which she does not
have to do in Salah because Salah is
supposed to be prayed every day of your
life minimum five times a day so there's
no question once she misses her Salah
maybe for 5 days 6 days 7 days whatever
it is when will she make up because
she's supposed to offer Salah every day
of her life but fasting is only
compulsory in the month of Ramadan so if
she misses for seven days in the month
of Ramadan she can very well compensate
for it after the month of Ramadan is
over therefore according to my thinking
according to my understanding that is
the Allah subhana wa ta'ala and our
beloved Prophet wasallam has told that
the woman should not make up for her
Salah if she miss during Minal period
but she has to make up for the fast
which she miss during ran